If we could go
back 100,000 years,
the closest thing that
there would be to a dog
would be their
ancestor, the wolf.
And these were fearsome
predators and probably not
animals that humans
out on the savannah
would be wanting to spend a lot
of time in close contact with.
Wolves domesticated
themselves, so wolves
started becoming interested
in human populations.
And they realized that they
could get some leftover scraps
of food and human refuse.
It was probably the wolves
that were the least fearful
and the least
aggressive who were
most successful in this niche on
the outskirts of human society.
And probably for
much of history,
we have not lived with dogs the
way that we live with dogs now.
In fact, most of the modern
breeds that we think about,
these are creations in the
last couple of hundred years.
They're products of
the Victorian era,
for the most part.
But we have a very deep
history with dogs going back
before this period
that we recognize
now was the way that
humans relate to dogs that
is much richer and certainly
goes back tens of thousands
of years.